- Sept fois plus de résidus
de certains pesticides dans
les framboises, trois fois
plus dans les bleuets :
c'est ce que propose
Santé Canada dans le cadre
de deux consultations publiques.
GÉRALD SÉVIGNY, producteur,
Ferme fruitière Sévigny
- Pour moi, c'est pas un besoin,
mais pas du tout. Au contraire,
on essaie plutôt de diminuer.
- L'incompréhension est totale
chez les producteurs de bleuets
du Québec, qui misent de plus
en plus sur le biologique.
DANIEL GOBEIL, prés. Syndicat
des producteurs de bleuets, Qc
- Extrêmement surpris, parce
qu'on n'en a pas entendu parler,
pantoute. Personne ne connaît
ces produits-là, fait que qui
a fait la demande et pourquoi?
- Les deux produits
en question sont le métalaxyl,
un fongidicide qui sert
à combattre la pourriture
des racines, et le sulfoxaflore,
un insecticide qui permet
de tuer les pucerons
et les punaises.
Pour les bleuets,
Santé Canada propose de faire
passer de 3 à 10 parties
par million la concentration
permise de métalaxyl,
et de 0,7 à 2 parties par
million le seuil autorisé
pour le sulfoxaflore.
Pour les framboises,
la concentration de métalaxyl
grimperait de 0,2 à 1,5 partie
par million.
- Il y a aucun producteur
qui demande ça.
- L'association qui représente
les producteurs de framboises
pense que la demande provient
des fabricants de pesticides,
qui souhaiteraient
un rehaussement des seuils
pour exporter leurs produits
plus facilement.
Une persective inquiétante,
selon elle, puisque certains
pays, comme le Mexique
ou le Chili, pourraient
profiter de l'occasion
pour écouler davantage
de framboises au Canada.
DAVID LEMIRE, prés. Asso. prod.
fraises et framboises du Qc
- C'est à nous à dire aux pays
exportateurs : bien, regardez,
si vous voulez rentrer
au Canada, bien, nous, nos
producteurs ont ces normes-là,
puis vous devez suivre ces mêmes
normes-là si vous voulez.
LOUISE VANDELAC, Institut des
sciences de l'environnement,UQAM
- Peu importe qui est
à l'origine, hein, que ce soit
les compagnies ou que ce soit
d'autres pays, le mandat
de Santé Canada, c'est
de protéger la santé
de sa population.
- Le premier ministre Trudeau
se fait rassurant.
- On se base sur la science pour
garder les gens en sécurité,
mais on compte aussi écouter
les experts, les citoyens qui
ont souvent des préoccupations
à ce niveau-là.
- L'entreprise Corteva,
qui vend du sulfoxaflore
au Canada, assure qu'elle n'a
pas formulé de demande pour
une hausse des seuils.
Pour sa part, Santé Canada
n'a pas été en mesure de
répondre à nos questions.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.